how handy men should talk to clients so
I have a great question from one of my
YouTube viewers Israel love you guys who
wrote in to say this is a great video
that really inspires me could you give
me some ideas and how to talk to clients
when I meet them I'm a handyman I will
appreciate your help thank you in
advance Israel this is a fantastic
question because you are in industry
where there is so little trust people
don't have trust for handyman for
construction workers whether they're
hiring to come in and fix things in
their homes because there's so much I
don't know the field look is such a
ripoff so many times and so the guy who
I love bringing on for example is always
busy and it's always hard to get a hold
of because he's somebody who I trust and
other people trust I love working with
him so we're going to keep giving him
good jobs so how do you get that first
job when you first go and talk to the
clients how do you start building that
rapport okay the first thing is number
one show up five minutes early this is a
little thing and this is before you even
talk to a client you know you ask me
what do I do when I talk to a client
this is before you even talk to a client
show up at least five minutes early why
because it's professional because so
many people who hire handyman to help
them are stuck with people who are
unreliable who don't show up on time who
rip them off who leave a project halfway
through and being incomplete and and
this is probably something that upsets
you and it should you know to know that
you're in an industry where so many
people are ripoff artists but this is
also your chance to stand out so show up
five minutes early to that first meeting
and are ready you're setting the tone
for a positive experience where I'm
meeting you and I feel like okay this
guy is this guy he showed up first of
all and he showed up early this is we're
off to a good start before we've even
said a single word number two is be
positive
a lot of handyman that I've worked with
and seen they
an attitude and you want to be positive
and support your customers okay you know
if I want to run a wire to one of my
rooms so I can have a new light in there
okay that may be something that's super
easy for you great but it's not
something that I know how to do I'm not
a technical guy I hire guys like you are
hire handymen to come in and help me
because you know I could hang a picture
in a wall but that may be the limit I am
not good at that kind of stuff
some people would come in and and so you
just want me to do that like that's so
easy to do don't make me feel bad about
hiring you to come in and help me
support me be positive right it may be
super easy for you may take you half an
hour to do but that's something that I
don't know how to do and that's why I'm
bringing you in so make me feel good be
excited be happy
listen to what I'm doing understand what
I'm trying to create if you have a
positive upbeat mentality then I'm going
to trust you and that's what you want to
build with every relationship that you
create when you start talking to clients
number three listen and ask questions
you have a tremendous opportunity on
each job that you go into to do
upselling to get more repeat business
and to get referrals but it doesn't
happen a lot because of the attitude
that most handy men go into I'm reminded
of of when I go to get the oil changed
for the car I always feel like I'm being
sold you know they come in and they say
okay we'll do the oil change but you
know this filter looks pretty dirty and
oh this thing is making some noises so
you might want to get a change and and I
just feel like I'm being sold and I feel
like I don't really need this thing and
and often I'll just say no because I
don't like the guy
and I don't feel like he really
understands me and I feel like is just
selling it to me and there's a
difference between selling somebody
something and really understanding what
their needs are and providing the
solution because you know what maybe my
filter is really dirty and maybe it is
really bad for my health and maybe it
does need to be changed but if you did a
better job at
connecting to me and making me feel like
you're here to help me not just to sell
me then I would probably buy from you
it's the same thing in the handyman
business if I'm hiring you to run a wire
then I'm going to need a lot more help
in the future right I'm going to need
something to help with a lot more stuff
and so you could be that guy if you
establish that positive rapport and and
you're listening to what I'm trying to
do and you're asking questions and
you're involved so if I'm trying to run
a wire turn your room to put a light
right so great okay you can do that
that's a half hour job whatever it is
fine you can ask well what are you what
are you doing what's your vision what
are you going to do in that room I'm
excited tell me about it and maybe I'm
telling you I want to create a new
entertainment area and I need the light
as my first step I need me ask me
questions what am I trying to do and and
you're not asking it just in that sales
way but be genuinely interested in your
customers imagine that as a concept like
actually care about your customers and
be interested in what they're doing and
I'll tell you my vision you know maybe I
want to have a full-on entertainment
area I'm going to bring in the TV or
home movie theater and I need seats and
I need built-ins and I'm gonna need a
whole bunch of stuff and maybe you get
excited by that vision and maybe you
give me advice and what I can do even if
it has nothing to do with you selling
your services just your advice some
things that you've seen because you're
an expert in this business and you
probably seen a lot more than I have
right if you are in it with me and
you're excited and you're sharing ideas
and I feel like that you understand what
I'm trying to do then of course I'm
going to give you more business and
you'll probably happen there on the spot
right it's like oh that's a cool idea
yeah yeah you know can you come and help
me make that built in or can you help me
you know put a tap in here so I can have
my wet bar whatever it is right if
you're connected to my vision and you're
excited and you're listening and you're
asking questions and I trust you that
I'm going to buy more from you I'm going
to refer clients to you you're going to
be so busy that you're going to have to
hire a team to start working for you or
you're going to start increasing your
prices that's how you start talking with
people as a handyman so remember show up
five minutes early be positive and
listen and ask questions believe for
those who are watching like the video
you can support me by clicking on the
link in the description leave a comment
below let me know what you think and
click on my face to subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon